it pleases me to no land to tell you
that the Fifty Shades trilogy is now
over it's over
[Applause]
[Music]
50 shades so Fifty Shades freed is the
concluding chapter to the Fifty Shades
trilogy cuz it's over so in this chapter
we have a little montage at the
beginning showing them getting married I
was like where they engaged did that
happen in the last one I don't remember
good news folks if you want to forget
something you can if you try hard enough
but in this movie they're dealing with
marriage and she has a stalker it's
pretty much the movie um say oh and you
know sex which I don't know what to say
I don't know how many times I can
address it any movie that uses sex as a
plot device or sex as the end game sex
is the point that's porn and this is
porn without any of the payoff all the
flaws apparent in the previous Fifty
Shades films they're a parent here so
this franchise if you can call it that
never evolved like now rated-r porn guys
what do you want but the sex scenes are
just uninteresting and the entire thing
hinges around this relationship you
don't give a [ __ ] about and you don't
even like them or care about them and
the relationship it's completely toxic
you see where she's sunbathing I believe
it was at a swimming pool might have
been a beach I started going to sleep
pretty early on in this one but I
believe it was the pool and she was like
yeah just take my bathing suit off he
was like not a chance you're showing
enough skin as it is ladies girls women
that is not normal leave him immediately
you can't change him and if you do it's
not gonna make you feel 50 shades free
it's gonna trap you and life's too short
to deal with that [ __ ] there's a big
problem in this movie most of this video
is going to be me bitching about the
relationship but since the relationship
is the point of the movie and the
driving force there to address it in a
review does that no point in this movie
do you feel like their relationship is
that of equal just tells young women out
there it's like well if he doesn't V you
as an equal
he can one day but it's not how that
[ __ ] works it's just a cycle of when
girls are young they're told boys pull
their hair because they like them and
it's probably true for the time but then
when boys become men they should
probably drop that [ __ ] those movies
like nah put up with it that's normal
and nothing could be further from
[ __ ] normal him going you're showing
enough skin who's that guy why are you
around attractive men because it's my
job and he's a [ __ ] author and I'm
his publicist what do you want what it
just comes across as toxic controlling
and basically what's wrong with
relationships today not all of them but
if this wasn't seen as normal to enough
people this movie wouldn't be made there
is one scene where he's pissed at her
creepily watches her slave he's like
come with me to the dungeon these starts
coming on to her and she was like I
thought
mad at me and if he had said I am but
I'm gonna revenge [ __ ] you really hard
it's gonna make me feel better because
that's healthy that would have been
honest because that was a situation at
least the movie addressed that was weird
it's inconsistent he didn't do this this
one time this is how he operates he's
insecure he deflects his insecurities
onto you you eat [ __ ] and deal with it
and what it reminds me of is that Edward
Bella [ __ ] when Edward in the
Twilight movies was like you're not
going to see Jacob which it is because
the Fifty Shades books they started out
as Twilight fan fiction which means when
I'm watching it the reason it feels like
high school middle school [ __ ] is
because it is this entire franchises
Twilight fan fiction it is based off of
high school romance so they act like
high school students but then I supposed
to be high school students but they are
skin like you get a video game and you
have a character that plays a certain
way then you get a skin to make that
character a different character which
still plays the same line like an
injustice to you get Raiden you have a
black lightning skin you can make him
black lightning but he plays like Raiden
so he's essentially still Raiden that's
what it is they're Twilight characters
but they're career-based adults they're
not everything from their communication
to their volatile emotions just shows
that they're high school students thank
God it's over now as I mentioned it's
over now if this were any other story
like if this were a rom-com Christian
Grey would be the dick boyfriend we
would want our protagonist good guy
character to steal the girl away from so
happens like guess he's the good guy but
you never really seem is the good guy
because he's a [ __ ] which crazy go
alright villain but how do you get past
that will you have another villain some
guy stalking her which also doesn't make
sense does it like here's security
footage of him stealing [ __ ] from your
building mr. gray it's like alright well
I'll put security on you you want to go
to the cops now I think security is good
I mean we have footage of him we
identified who he is but let's not go to
the cops ready they talk about how he's
been missing for a month but didn't even
try no point where they like yeah dude
police report totally I guess I just
talked about the acting acting terrible
it's just not better you know I mean
blessum the cast in here Matt they're
there for the paycheck and good for them
they've got their paycheck they never
have to do another one of these movies
because that's right it's over now
for them honestly I was more interested
in the girl who wanted to bang The
Bodyguard at least that was honestly she
was like I just want one night with that
dude which is pretty much what the main
two are like but they're just there
miserably married now you can just tell
the entire premise that this story was
written by someone who just doesn't know
how to write like when she kind of drops
the hints about like well do you want
kids and he was like um um she's like
look you eventually do want kids though
right I'm just thinking you probably
should have talked about this before
that wedding montage at the beginning of
the movie you didn't know if you wanted
kids late you just married him as in the
end I will say this the script for this
one was better than the second one least
there's no weird helicopter crash that
then he just comes back and he's fine it
means nothing
I guess this movie's version of that is
the last 15 minutes of the movie where
they're like it's all wrapped up right
here some family backstory that you
didn't ask for the end so I guess you
find out about his past and I suppose
there's an interesting story in there
somewhere
movie didn't execute it at all back they
make the whole thing the resolution the
point of all of it and afterthought like
I don't care about them if I didn't care
about them after being waterboarded for
six hours of these movies I'm not gonna
start now my only regret is I didn't
leave the movie theater when I wanted to
like when it's clear it's like all right
it's all done now there's just wrap up I
wanted to leave and I was like maybe I
should stick around I was like nope that
was useless shoulda left fifty Shades
freed took two hours out of my life I
could not tell you which of these movies
is the worst one all I could say is it's
painful it's horrible it's useless or
relationships toxic I'm fifty Shades
freed is in fact dog [ __ ] but hey at
least it's over
[Applause]
every ugly cry because something
Horrible's over Verizon Fifty Shades
freed have you say I [ __ ] hope you
haven't so I'm gonna assume you have not
seen the Fifty Shades movie so what
issues the worst movie ever made for you
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]